how's it going citizens of the reject
nation john here for a solo movie
reaction thank you for joining me we're
going to watch pray the fifth film in
the predator
standalone franchise uh i'm very excited
for this really enjoyed the trailers
really excited to see how this take
plays out i love the time and place
they've chosen to set it in so we'll see
obviously it's hard to top the original
predator dylan
is one of my all-time favorite movie
meme moments and i got love for
predators as well and i could never
forget avp the movie that unfortunately
taught me in the heat of a trivia match
uh the difference between the arctic and
antarctica so that's the thing but
anyhow greg and i were originally going
to check this out together and
unfortunately the vid diesel caught up
with us and we also had a round of press
interviews to do with the cast director
and producer so he unfortunately had to
go off ahead of me so i am catching up
now but if you haven't seen those
interviews please go give them a look
greg did an excellent job and actually
after shooting all of this we were given
the opportunity to cover the red carpet
premiere for prey do some interviews
there meet the actual cast and crew in
person it was a very very cool
experience so if you want to check some
of that out it's on the channel as well
so check those out if you haven't seen
those and as always if you could leave a
like on this video that would help out a
lot as well as just a comment including
your thoughts on the movie or anything
else you want to talk about subscribe
hit that notification bell to get
notified every single time something
interesting comes out on the channel you
will be informed and if you'd like to
get the full experience go beyond the
reaction highlights you can come on over
to our patreon page patreon.com the real
rejects that's where you can sync up
with your own copy enjoy the full movie
alongside me or a bunch of other shows
and movies that we have exclusive
reaction highlights as well as watch
alongs for last but not least cannot
forget the folks over at prepper for
handling these highlights cutting them
down making them look all nice for you
guys very much appreciate them and uh
yeah without further ado man
let's watch us some pray
a long time ago
it is said a monster came here
okay
it's like a folk tale
oh
i wonder just how many reactions the
first time people see the dog they go oh
[Music]
blue on those flowers really pops huh
it's freaking sound effects man
you want to go out to one of those
axe throwing ranges such a satisfying
sound
[Music]
oh
[Music]
no
[Music]
at least it's just a tail though
yeah you knew that wasn't the
ordinary thunderstorm i remember when
father told me i was ready for katan
went up into the hills
the rain was bad everything was wet we
crawled through the mud my bowstring got
ruined
ah yeah you were sleeping
now you're gonna have to cross the river
to get it it's time i'm ready for my
katamia you want to hunt something
that's hunting you
uh-huh there's a theme for you
i guess that is the true battle
is if you can outwit something that's
coming for you specifically
attention to detail is awesome
trained him well
it's easy he's smart
not every smart creature is easy to
train
like you most likely
your father left you that
to cut bread root with you almost got a
deer with it why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
yeah that's fair in this wind he brings
home a red tail
of course
meanwhile this dude is just
cruising around
looking for a place to
uh park game is a foot
each little predator at least thus far
like each little predator appearance has
been really well like spaced out i keep
getting lulled into just like
the life
on display
hina a lion he took bowie you got to
find him
who invited you
we won't be gone long enough need to
cook
hey she tracks well
if we find pouya alive
she knows medicine
yeah bro
oh
[Laughter]
a fighter snake i don't care
as that was that was a very clever [ __ ]
so cool
i love the the rhythm with which they're
depicting all these things
like how resourceful they are and how
like synchronized they are
tommy wants to stay and hunt let's go
i'm coming with you
i can't handle the life it's not just
the world i've got this
we don't have time to waste talking we
need to get him home yeah quiet lois men
are talking
[Music]
so many
beautiful shots in this movie like jeez
okay
the cold is good the medicine slows his
blood if he gets warm he'll bleed out
hey
do you want him to be comfortable or
alive mia
[Laughter]
ah you knew that was coming pete
snake's been waiting there all day like
i got one left in me
one good death rattle
oh
look
it could be bear tracks
maybe
but that's a big bear and why was it on
its hind legs and what skin's a snake
like that we need to keep moving no i
have to warn my brother pakka go with
there what do i gotta go with her why'd
you come back
i found tracks
and they were huge
i'm not frightened by a bear i don't
think it was a bear or whatever it was
we're in the cat's den now we have to
deal with the first now's your shot
it'll think it's hunting us a hunter
doesn't eat
he hunts
like a beer all night we could stock the
forest all night and not find anything
too
will bait it
then i'll lead the cat to you it's time
you cut them here and the line comes
you tell that thing
this is as far as you go
no more
this is it as far as you go no more
this is it like each time i'm afraid
it's gonna go that way like i'm like
okay like i like their relationship so
far which is also why i'm afraid he's
about to get murked like right now
you've never faced a lion
this mouth full of teeth like arrows
ready to tear your flesh when your
brother comes back
he and i will find the lion
and kill him
[Laughter]
this is a good jump scare
oh
cool
oh damn
what a shot damn that is that is a lion
jesus man the shots
your brother carried you home you think
the reason for kotamiya is to prove you
can hunt
but there's only one
reason to survive
that's the sage way of looking at that
actually
the hunt isn't the full picture
[Music]
jesus
we did it
we didn't do it what do you think left
those tracks and before i fell i saw
lightning in the church there's
something else okay well i'll hunt alone
if i have to you can't
you're right
we didn't do it
i did
you tried it
you just
you couldn't bring it home
oh
war chief gonna have his day
[Music]
if they don't see
we'll show them
i wonder how they lit this movie like a
lot of this looks really
really natural which i guess has become
sort of a meme lately but
it looks really great here it looks
really beautiful
[Music]
nice nice match cut
this aerial shots and these landscape
shots like
it feels like you're watching some kind
of
like
like a ken burns documentary crashed
into like a nature special
or something
owner oh i gotta check the race this
movie rated r for goo
that's a big foot
wow
dang
a little green in his teeth
her teeth there too
freaking squaring off
don't go no don't don't oh
[Music]
so mortal kombat of you
bro jesus pray is a really good title
for this movie
like so much food chaining all around
yes
oh cool
does that mean we're gonna get like an
elaborate dog hunting scene
[Music]
chew stick
gotta get your oral hygiene
what national park do they shoot this in
or was it just canada
brutal
fairy metal
[Applause]
he's a scout too he's collecting belt
loops
ah so cool
that's so awesome
ugh
yeah some didn't look right
ugh
[Music]
my stogy
i know i left that cigar here somewhere
oh no
of course
this looks like it was fun to shoot
uh
it's like pita in the hunger games with
the the cake frosting blending in
huh
hey
well done this movie is a very cool
sound design
expressive sound design
[Music]
and now she's covered in mud
clever
sorry it took me it took me a second
okay less covered in mud
this dog is really good too like i call
them animal actors i'm like in this case
i'm like yeah
he's a very good boy
whoa
there's a scar and a half
oh
ah [ __ ]
and now it becomes the edge
[Music]
who's afraid of the bear now
this bear's been here this whole time
like i heard what you said you was
afraid of a barrel jews afraid of a bear
[Music]
i i have a feeling a lot of people are
gonna be sitting there going as long as
the dog's okay
you can massacre as many rabbits bears
buffalo whatever
oh my god
[Music]
oh
damn
oh he caught up
holy [ __ ]
let that be a lesson to you
look at that
that is pretty freaking metal
jesus christ
so much for that camo boy
looking for you
your brother sent us to bring you home
i saw what left those tracks i couldn't
see it until it was covered in blood but
it looked like like a moot beats
it fought and killed a bear with its
hands easily how come it didn't kill you
thanks thanks bro
[Music]
[Laughter]
jesus
you want to live
[Music]
there's something else
i like to think the predator collects
this footage and then does like silly
voice overs
stupid possums don't even believe that
possum's dead though you know how they
are
[Laughter]
wow
oh
[ __ ]
come on you got a clever trick up your
sleeve
oh no
gotta conserve those darts man
that faceplate holy [ __ ]
oh
[Laughter]
taking heads man
[Music]
yeah you want to talk battle cries
i really
am enjoying the way that they're
using the cloaking
jesus
is that what it sounds like to be in the
predator's helmet
no
no no no no
no it's close
[Music]
yeah i was going to say
you can't outrun predators
spray
[Music]
oh
chekhov's bear trap
god dammit
[Music]
are they french
oh
you better be careful with that dog
[Laughter]
yeah in the most [ __ ] wasteful way
possible it's a great gag too because at
first you're like would predator do that
and you're like oh wait maybe not
nope that's just us
i think this creature
is a hunter
if you were smart you would help us tell
us
something like the last sacred point
there's something about a savage
oh no
that's all how do they have him too
geez
it's like raiders
that's what you went out after
it's what you were
tracking yes
and that's what you chose for good dummy
[Laughter]
great user perspectives man
it's a great way to play into like the
slasher movie quality
it's coming
[Music]
he's coming for us no
it doesn't want paid it doesn't hunt
that way
before the trappers captured me
it saw me and then left
i didn't think i was a threat
oh see you're not a mary sue
your plan
the tree
you weakened it
you had it nadu
oh
you can see what i made
he always had
i don't know that this thing can be
killed
the lion though they did it together
if it bleeds
we can kill
[Music]
[Laughter]
snuck it right in there dude but like ah
[Laughter]
perfect camper on that scene oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
ah that's so freaking cool
bro
sorry
good effort
[Laughter]
oh
remember old guns
remember muskets
remember reload time
[Applause]
oh
get the head [ __ ]
he's like yeah it's a good kill it's a
good kill
the
losing his leg to be free
wait
not what are you doing nader
nada stop
huh
i'll get sweaty
parkour
[Music]
these guys are all really well cast like
they feel like they're out of a
different time
yes this will go well
keep on watching the show's about to
begin
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
badass
this is a really cool movie man
this is really cool
like they still got to stick the landing
but so far like it's nice to have like a
really punchy solid predator movie
now
[Music]
oh
god way to shoot this action too
oh
jesus
oh
jesus
oh jesus
[Laughter]
oh
i swear the little hatchet with the
the rope on it just
coolest freaking tweak
oh
god
well done with the focus like hide them
out of sight oh ow ooh
and i'll show you how to use it
this guy looks kind of like the geico
cave man
take the ball
and put it in the garden
watch
ah
pull that back
and it will fire
that's all
yeah you need i don't know it'll create
a spark
what's easy
[Music]
shut up and take your medicine i'm
freezing cold
are you still a threat oh my god
yes possum
and the predator surveyed the wreckage
with the coldest blue outlook as if to
say that he is one and the same with the
thermal readout on his screen that with
which he sees all of life
jesus
props to represent
a well-timed jesus
between predator and and naru and
the focusrack like
[Applause]
you're so close
no
though no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
oh geez that was that was close still
oh and get what you got to think for
masks my guy
no
hey
[Music]
[Music]
jeez
ah
cheater not so tough when you're
invisible this is as far as i go
no
this is it
no
oh no no no no
[Music]
[Music]
there's the white hot in her eyes
[Music]
not going out without a fight though oh
[Laughter]
they're really great at
emphasizing things with sound
like the way they framed that like you
knew
his moment was nigh but like
like they're really good at sort of
arresting you in the moment with
an interesting sound choice or something
like that
we keep watching all this time
you really are the best boy
oh my dudes back
[Laughter]
of course this guy's the one who made it
jesus christ
[Music]
no
that's one fierce slap bracelet
this guy's eyes are just always about to
pop right out of his head
oh
that's twisted
oh
no
you think that i'm not a hunter like you
oh
that is what makes me dangerous
hey go see you coming
you can't see
but i'm killing you
[Laughter]
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
oh
that can't be i mean are you doing okay
how much of your brain is left after
that
you want your helmet how many abs does
he have
she that i don't know you know predator
you don't need to gender the predator
oh nice
oh that was awesome
love that
it's that touch with the glowing
translucent blood
[Laughter]
oh
take that bro
[Music]
oh he's mad now
he's very mad he underestimated you
now he's actually trying
oh [ __ ]
oh
jesus oh jesus no
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
hog time
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
think i give a [ __ ] about some sinkhole
this is as far as you go
no more
this is it
this is it
yep
yes
oh my god
you earned that
[Music]
[Laughter]
i told you guys it was bigger than a
bear
[Music]
so cool
the way they painted that on her face
like
i don't know i feel like that could
easily look silly but it
it does look convincing
like such a literal contrast to when
tommy comes back with the
[Laughter]
nice man
hell yeah
oh
god that was that was very cool that
flew by too like it was really really
tight
things that are paced well and use their
style to enhance every little emotional
nuancer tight
i love that
the actual like cave painted predator
god well done
i gotta say i mean as much as the
opening title sequences is something
that i love you know a good
interesting opening title i do
appreciate that people throw down for
these you know creative end credit
sequences as well those are for people
like me
and again man the title prey like it's
perfect oh
oh
oh
the predator will return
for the comanche nation
wow
see that's cool too because it i think
greg brought this up in the uh interview
too is like as much as these are
exploitation movies like this this does
feel
very earnest in the way that it portrays
the comanche and and the way that it
uses their sort of way of life as the
setting and the sort of time and place
this is a really nice blend between
something that yeah feels authentic to
the time i i'm no expert on you know
uh native american history or anything
like that but yeah just like the way
that it took time to observe those
things and then also do a bunch of you
know crazy predator [ __ ] like is really
really well balanced and pitched and
conceived hey adi
i should have known yeah
amalgamated dynamics they do a lot of
the predator stuff
back in the old days at uh fangoria we
went there we visited we did a blood and
guts episode about it all right i think
we are we are good on all the different
credit scenes that there could be i'm
going to take the risk and uh we are
going to hop into the review
uh yeah
all right man i mean yeah
i mean if you've been here with me this
whole time or for the reaction
highlights or whatever uh i mean it's i
think it's pretty evident that i quite
enjoyed this movie and uh you know i
mean when we did the trailer reactions
at the outset i was
reasonably optimistic i mean you know as
everyone up until this point has
clarified and you know reiterated the
predator franchises of varying quality
um but you know the promise of you know
something a little more simple and a
little more straightforward and a little
more back to basics for predator seemed
uh
you know like a good one
and that's a choice i appreciate in
general you know when you take something
that is you know science fiction heavy
or very futuristic or that relies on a
certain amount of like futuristic
technology or weaponry or things like
that when you take
you know that idea and then you
transplant it into a time that's much
more rudimentary or analog or just you
know based on the elements and on nature
uh i feel like that can temper the
science fiction in a really rewarding
way that forces you know the filmmakers
to get a little clever like it's not the
same kind of thing but like when uh you
know going from watching like the mcu
and agents of shield then to checking
out agent carter uh was like a really
nice breath of fresh air because while
agent carter still had like a lot of the
sci-fi context and you know uh scenarios
and mcguffins and whatever it was often
tempered by the fact that we were in
like the 30s and 40s very different from
this time and place but a similar kind
of again the word i keep going for is
tempering of the fact that yes like
you're not in the future it's not
spaceships nobody has like machine guns
like the weapons that you have are
either made out of again found objects
wood and string or else they're like
very rudimentary guns for the most part
and that goes to highlight in a
situation like this too i think
especially
the the idea that it's not the weapon
you know so much as it is the wielder
the hunter you know the predator itself
and uh trusting dan trachtenberg from
things like 10 cloverfield lane and just
again the interesting hook of this
historical fiction period piece crashed
into you know something that looks
pretty familiar like a predator movie
yeah i had a lot of optimism coming into
this but um i was just constantly
surprised at every turn by just
how much care and how much um just
attention to detail
in almost every regard seemed to have
gone into this movie like
you know it it would have been pretty
easy i think to make this relatively
speaking to make this a satisfying cool
movie but i guess pretty easy is
probably the wrong phrase all things
considered but you know i feel like they
could have easily made a pretty good
predator movie that wasn't necessarily a
good movie whereas here i think it
manages to be both and as much as i like
predators i feel like that might be what
holds that movie back uh from certain
people's like full enthusiasm is like
yeah as a movie it might not be that
great as a predator movie is pretty cool
but yeah this movie i think manages
very successfully to be both and i would
happily like have this movie kind of
like separated in some kind of
you know d fusion in a fission machine
or something like that and i would
probably still watch both movies i would
probably just watch like the silent film
about predator tracking through the
woods and
you know the the comanche movie about
this girl coming of age and going on you
know this spiritual rite of passage i
really gotta kind of commend everyone
involved for helping it sort of
transcend that into being
you know not more than it needs to be
but like really really conscientiously
and really thoughtfully what it needs to
be and it does bring elements that you
don't necessarily need in a predator
movie but i think really
help this movie and i mean i think uh as
i think greg said this in his in his
interviews with the cast you know this
he said this was the most he had cared
about a character in the predator
franchise i mean obviously everyone
loves arnold
dutch but uh yeah i mean they give you
this juxtaposition
of the predator doing its its hunter
thing you know traversing the galaxy
searching for you know to steal the it
word of a couple years ago the apex
predator of whatever ecosystem he's in
squaring off with that you know creature
whatever it may be and bringing back
that head as a trophy and then on the
other side of that you have you know
this young budding warrior who wants to
prove her salt but is having trouble
with that and
yeah you you have this very sort of
thoughtful and and um
i don't know very natural kind of
depiction it would seem
of life in this comanche camp and
you know again the uh what they call it
the katamiya uh i hope i'm saying that
right this sort of com the the rite of
passage the coming of age ritual in
which you sort of pick
your uh you know the predator or yeah
again
the themes of prey and predator are so
like well laced into like every scene of
this movie just the way different
creatures and people and and all
different points on the food chain kind
of occupy both of those roles in
different points in time so i'm probably
going to say the words predator and prey
a lot in here um but yeah you know you
you have your sort of white whale that
you need to go out and slay as part of
this coming-of-age mission and i liked
the nuances that came of that especially
with the mom and the brother uh you know
the way she she kind of uh checks naru
uh in the middle point of the movie
where you know uh tabe has to bring her
back
uh and she says you know like it's not
about hunting it's not about proving
yourself as a hunter necessarily it's
about surviving and it is an interesting
thing i mean it's
not not comforting i'm sure to hear that
because you know you gotta achieve
but uh this this movie again like around
every
corner kept impressing me with the
things it chose to embellish
in spite of how simple certain aspects
of it are it's a simple
journey in a sense for this character in
terms of a story you know she wants to
prove herself to her tribe and her
family and she wants to be taken
seriously and she wants to prove to
herself that she has the ability to you
know follow her instincts for tracking
and for hunting
and you know to serve the tribe in that
way and to be recognized for those
skills not just the skills of medicine
but but two even still
not like issuing those either by the end
like as a character journey i thought
they did really nicely to sort of bring
her full circle by the end you know to
bring her to a sort of completion or to
like a next
uh iteration you know in her growth and
and her journey but yeah like to show
somebody who has a whole lot of
potential at the outset who has natural
skills and abilities but who needs to
hone them and who needs to mature in the
face of the elements and in the face of
all the interconnecting concerns of a
hunt and you know the tribe ecosystem
just the ecosystem of the land around
and two i mean the way the movie
utilizes the elements as its own sort of
natural but still predatory force
is really well engaged and is something
that i think is is another one of those
primal aspects that
you know even if you're not used to
spending a lot of time outdoors you know
you can still relate to you know if you
were thrust into that situation you
would have these things just probably
just as many things at your disposal so
like there is something innate about
that that i think too they use very
nicely to their advantage and as a foil
just as much as it is sort of an asset
to the characters and i mean props to
the entire cast but especially to amber
mid thunder and dakota beavers as well
for just like really throwing themselves
full-heartedly it appears into these
roles and into you know both the acting
side of it but also the physical side of
it just like getting out into the
elements and you know uh doing this
combat and and writing and and you know
digging around in the muck and the mud
and everything like really really
challenging i would imagine to be on set
for but also i mean i just thought they
they really committed and really brought
the authenticity and and sold the whole
thing wonderfully again they just put so
much more care and effort than they had
to and i really really loved that
because again it's both in the writing
like the dialogue and the the story at
hand isn't like the most crazy intricate
deep thing but the combination of the
dialogue and the this character journey
they created combined with the
performances
i think just really made this come to
life in a way that like really makes it
easy to sink into perspectives and
that's on the filmmaking too i mean hats
off to dan trachtenberg's direction
because the way the movie shifts between
perspectives and i mean i'm talking like
character perspectives but sometimes
you're in the predator's perspective
sometimes you're in the perspective of
just animals and things like that and
the way the camera sometimes even glides
you between those things in the same
shot uh
with a rack of focus or a subtle you
know angle shift or whatever a subtle
motion like there's so many great
really solid choices and there are cool
shots and [ __ ] and there's like a bunch
of stuff that's really striking
but all that stuff is really well
chosen i feel like like this is a great
example again of like a really
solidly directed movie that has like a
bunch of cool stuff in it but it's like
really concerned on just selling and
enhancing and embellishing
the most important aspects which in this
are you know your characters to make
sure that you actually care about what's
going on so it's not just a bloodbath
and then yeah like paying homage to and
giving us those like nerdy fan moments
that we want to see of the predator and
i i liked very much the way that they
built the predator up over the course of
the movie and these little appearances
you know the ship goes by and
intermingling that with folk tales and
things like that i i forget the the
certain names she says at one point when
she's describing
you know what she saw to the other guys
uh who you know she she's
hunting with and and who are you know
sort of like keeping an eye on her while
tommy's out looking for her and and uh
you know she says it like looks like
this mythical creature and you know
there's like the firebird myth uh that
that
i think they named check at one point um
you know like and i'm no expert on these
things so i cannot like reiterate them
for you here and now off the dome um but
yeah like the way that they
played that into
you know folklore and sort of spiritual
belief
and then
you know even though we know it's not
quite that it kind of is and like it's
those little philosophical flourishes
too that i think are kind of nice
because yeah like it is her katamia
eventually like
whether you like it or not you know like
she is the one who kind of notices and
knows to take the predator seriously and
and two like i love the theme they use
of of it not seeing her as a threat and
it's you know i mean anytime you have uh
a female lead and a movie like this
that's known for like macho dudely
characters i feel like people get up in
arms about wokeness and primary suit but
i thought they made like a really great
wonderful character journey in a
physical sense like not only are you
watching you know her um you know her
her self-worth improvement and we're
watching her you know persevere and use
you know the best of her knowledge and
instincts but we watch her really have
to learn and observe
and it is in that sense of you know
using that underestimation as an asset
like it doesn't see me as a threat but
that's how what makes me threatening now
is because i've been able to observe
like you watch the predator tracking and
stuff throughout the movie and nadu is
kind of doing that too and even in that
sense you kind of have like this this
sort of
like polar sort of attraction that leads
them together through the action of the
story and two i thought they had clever
takes on that theme of invisibility of
cloaking yourself to avoid i mean
literally usually the predator's you
know thermal vision
but doing that on multiple levels where
it's like yeah they have a means of of
you know becoming invisible by ingesting
the the orange tootsie of the flower uh
but also
you know she has that added
layer at least for for naru where it's
you know he doesn't see me because he's
not concerned with me and i thought the
way that they you know utilized that
i'll talk about that a little bit more
in a bit but the way that they utilized
that
i thought was was a nice two-fold that
almost like helped that they they
homaged the whole getting caked in mud
thing without actually having to use
that because like that's the one thing
about like predators
is like adrien brody at one point pretty
much just does the dutch and covers
himself in mud and like it's cool and
all that but i thought here like they
they came up with ways to use that but
as both a theme and a physical
phenomenon that's not the exact same
thing so just like props for
for like easter egging and expounding on
that you know
yeah and i mean even the predator like
you know i like to that this is
i mean this is you know 300 odd years an
hour past currently
and
uh you know i don't have the best grip
on like every i can't pinpoint every
predator movie on the timeline but in
setting this beforehand
uh
you know i feel like it also gives you
this kind of interesting view on like
because the predator doesn't speak you
can kind of ascribe any sort of other
story detail headcanon you want to it so
in a way it's almost like this predator
is on its own sort of journey of at
least conquest perhaps some kind of you
know coming of age or rite of passage
for uh you know that species of
predators
also just a sidebar but i love the sort
of tweaked design they went with for the
predator i mean that's obviously very
much akin to the designs that have come
before or that will come in the future
um but yeah with the slightly more
narrow face and again that bone
plate sort of giving it again a slightly
more tribal and a slightly more
primitive
uh aesthetic to sort of match again
being so far removed in time or being so
far back in the past like i thought that
was again
subtle tweaks
um and i think they're they're i mean
there are definitely like gadgets and
guns and stuff like that that are like
direct easter eggs from other predator
movies but i thought the design choice
here was was really cool and really
suited again without being a direct
overhaul just the aesthetic of the movie
at hand but even so like i thought that
was complimentary and there were so many
things that had these like dual
components or that would you know be
important at one point or come up at one
point and then come back whether it be
like the sinkhole uh at first being this
like major obstacle for nadu to you know
figure her way out of and then later to
come back and use as part of her
ultimate you know finishing move
um but yeah like all that stuff like
even running into the trappers and sort
of seeing two i love that like that that
switcheroo like you see this field full
of decimated buffalo or bison or
whatever and you think to yourself like
oh my god you know predators really
laying it down but then the further you
get and the more you realize like but
they couldn't have been like that
threatening right like they're not the
apex predators of the region they're not
you know the bears or the wolves or the
snakes or whatever
so yeah i love that switcheroo of like
the cigar as a sort of not mcguffin but
just yeah like a sign a harbinger of
like oh no
no it's not what you think and i feel
like that's something that you know it's
like i would have almost missed that um
but yeah like having even that come
around is like okay
you know there's monstrousness within us
and there's that sort of primal like
when your back's up against the wall you
just have to you know either fight
or
die
in this situation if you're up against
the predator there's
pretty much two choices
um but yeah like the the way that they
kind of constructed this very uh
naturally unfolding journey they're you
know out uh
there's a lion in the area it slashed up
one of their uh you know tribes people
and they gotta go you know find the lion
and
you know neutralize it and bring it back
and kind of
restore order to the food chain of the
area
and then yeah that kind of
uh kind of yeah just like intersecting
with this predators just sort of uh
walkabout
of
you know supremacy of just you know like
taking on all the greatest uh you know
beasts in the area and whatnot and they
just happen to stumble upon these guys
but even so like
i really enjoyed again i've used the
word probably tangibility a lot i like
the tangibility of this quite a bit
because you know you really do feel like
you are you feel the the land you feel
that some of the time that it takes to
get places and the distance and again
like i said this before it's like you
know 10 cloverfield lane does so much
with a tight confined space in this
movie
obviously you're outdoors for pretty
much all of it unless you're you know
inside a hut or a tp or something so uh
you know
you ring a lot of
i guess agoraphobia out of that and
claustrophobia because of you know the
things that can be lurking between trees
and i thought they did a really nice job
too in this movie of using the
predator's cloaking ability as sort of
its own presence like for so much of the
movie even though you know what's coming
i feel like the cloaking mechanism is
especially useful for something like
this because
you can only do so many flybys before
you have to have an actual like no
predator appearance
and i thought the way that they used the
stealth especially for when he's you
know like quietly observing things like
i would be curious to go back and look
through this and see like are there more
times where you can see him lurking
than you even realize um but yeah like
the way that they used that and the way
that in the different you know
altercations the different fights and
things like it was spark and you would
see like patches
and stuff like that like i thought that
was a really just sort of sinister and
really cool looking
motif that again you know it it goes to
show that while that's like a major
asset while the predator does have like
you know so many
abilities to just make the fight like
unfair you know like he's he's got like
tracking and and you know he can
pinpoint targets and and all that other
stuff and you know he's got these blades
and
you know it's things like that that
helped kind of even the playing field
and make it feel like yeah you know this
is a an alien being from an advanced
race engineer to hunt and kill but you
know i believe that part of
part of the point of doing that and part
of maybe even the thrill if you want to
ascribe such a you know emotional value
to a predator is the risk you know is
the danger factor is like what would be
the point if not to say that you brought
back the skull of something particularly
dangerous and
i i love the the choice to set this in
the comanche nation to set this among
people who live off the land and who you
know really know how to
make everything you need to survive out
of everything that is just kind of here
now and doesn't need uh
you know it's like either the figuring
out is in you know like making the
gurney like i love that scene where
she's applying the ointments and they
are you know taking bits and pieces and
they're making this gurney and they are
doing it like clockwork because they
have to and it's like you can see how
uh tabe is you know in his position and
i loved again like i called out in the
reactions like i really enjoyed that
they made him a real
nuanced character that you know does
seem to care for his sister he has his
own pride but he does stick up for her
and he does support her especially as
the rest of the you know tribe that
they're with is you know laughing at her
and belittling her and whatever else um
you know i really enjoyed their
relationship together and i like that
you're like yeah he is you know an
instrumental part of it and then you
have that flipperoo or is that the you
know when they do the lion hunt you know
it's her plan and he puts his faith in
her and she is instrumental in getting
it done which he ultimately admits to
later but she didn't yeah fully bring it
home he needed to complete that whereas
at the end it's the reverse it's like he
is able to help he's able to get her
that critical window but she's the one
who over the course of this went out and
looked for this creature and
observed
its habits and its fight style and and
how it hunts and all that stuff like
she gets this this fascinatingly like
you know hyper physical and fight or
flight but also like very
oddly kind of intimate
glimpse at how this creature works and i
think again that linchpin and i know uh
you know i don't know
if he saw her as a threat at one point i
guess you could argue like why didn't he
just kill her anyway but i liked that
motif and i liked giving the predator a
bit of agency because like the body
language i thought was really great like
i really loved the blend of i'm sure
there's a lot of cg shots but i also
really got the sense of the actor in the
suit you know bringing some of that
slasher movie personality um you know i
mean the noise and the articulation of
the you know face and the mask or you
know puppeteering all the combination of
that movie magic
brings that to life but two just the
thought that the predator might be able
to make a choice like that make a
decision like that
regarding its hunt
and then you know have that come back
around like that red as a true
thing to me
that you might encounter just out in the
wild in the sort of
natural order of a you know hostile food
chain so yeah like this this was just an
experience where again like the music
like i i really appreciated that too
like i thought they did nicely to ground
the music
in
you know like there's certain flavors
that i'm sure like trophy by this point
that you expect to hear in a native
american setting no matter what that is
uh you expect to hear like drums or
flutes and things like that or certain
vocalizations and there is that and and
there is i think tasteful use of that
but there are also just
period-appropriate instruments and then
where appropriate it seems as well
certain like synth flourishes
and yeah i just like it i thought they
really expressively used the music in a
way that felt again very natural and and
sort of tangible even though it is you
know part of the more heightened aspect
of movie magic
um uh but yeah like the sound effects uh
especially like that that tomahawk
hitting the wood each time and that that
you know the tomahawk with the rope on
it you know like great great call it
reminded me of i don't know what that
martial art is called but you know where
you have like the dagger on the end of
the the rope um yeah just just like this
had so many great
elements that like are befitting of
the cool fun [ __ ] you want from and you
know predator movies or exploitation
movies they're fun action horror
you know adventures in their own way but
they're also exploitation movies and so
you have those exploitable elements but
you also have an earnest story and also
an earnest depiction of its you know
subjects in you know the sort of culture
the comanche nation that they chose to
sort of center the the story around and
to sort of build their characters out of
like that was something that i was very
curious about going into this because
obviously you see like
it's an indigenous cast for the most
part uh pretty much completely um and
and you know there are people uh working
behind the scenes producers and whatnot
who are uh of comanche uh descent as
well as you know uh various other
indigenous cultures but it's one of
those things where you see it and you're
like ah this could easily just be like a
nifty idea that they're not gonna really
dive into at all that is just gonna be
kind of a skin to lay over top of this
to make it seem like it's fresh um yeah
there are a lot of ways that this could
have been cynical or trite but i thought
they really too while it's not like a
deep historical dive
into you know the nuances of comanche
life uh it does take time to observe
that though like when you're in the camp
you know it lets you drink in those
details and it seems like they really
did just kind of build what appears to
be an actual camp and just kind of let
life unfold there as it might have and
the way they chose to capture that just
felt very again observant and
compassionate and
you know very informed by something
authentic you know like it seemed like
they really cared to make this life feel
real and tangible and and as well
informed
by you know some actual history as
possible so yeah like even if it's not
the quote-unquote point i was really
happy to see that they didn't just use
it as just kind of like oh it's a neat
you know kind of
uh a gimmick i guess that's it it wasn't
a gimmick for this movie it was very
very much ingrained in the heart and
soul and the core story of this and so
that's something that like
again i i was a little worried they
might fumble but they they very much did
not
and you have really beautiful
cinematography with really beautiful
lighting that really
puts you in the setting
and then two uh like i i cannot i'm
really excited to watch the comanche dub
of this because i mean i i don't know i
i love seeing things like this that very
naturally kind of lend a platform and
very naturally kind of give people a
reason to sort of take an interest in
history or a different culture or
whatever
um and yeah so like i'm really excited
to watch uh the dub and just sort of
take it in that way but i love the way
that they too kind of use
a certain level of like there's dialogue
obviously it drives a lot of the story
uh you know of the personal journey uh
journey of naru and her you know close
uh you know her brother and her her
tribe and all that stuff but there's so
much of this movie that is just about
body language and physicality and there
is a lot of the story that could be told
without words you know and so i like too
that
even
uh language
can be a barrier and can represent sort
of um
i don't know the the difference between
winding up predator or prey in a certain
situation
uh you know ostensibly the guy who is
like the one vaguely sympathetic dude
with the french camp with the trappers
you know it's like i guess he could have
spoken to tabe but like you know their
ability and willingness to communicate
in that moment you know it's like you
you hear french and they don't subtitle
it so you're like you're kept on the
outside and that too like i think during
the trailer we had theorized that these
would be like you know
english speaking settlers of some sort
um but i love that choice too because
that's another thing that makes you go
like oh wait a minute so let me figure
out where exactly in the in the plains
we are and let me go crack a history
book again because that's kind of
interesting um but also yeah like it
creates again another barrier that uh
puts you
uh sets you uneasy you know it's uh yeah
it's it's another way in which you could
you know
like lose that critical edge in being
able to you know scrape out of a
situation
or avoid you know some kind of ill fate
and i mean they are like
like a pretty horrible bunch for the
most part so it does make for a very
sort of satisfying slashery kind of
act three when they're all getting
hacked up and they tie them to the you
know big stump and they you know are
using them as baits but uh yeah like
watching just the whole thing crescendo
into some really cool action sequences
with again the requisite amounts of like
gore and viscera and like really kind of
cringe inducing stomach churning
gags but again it's not just gor gorgorg
or gore like there is a good amount of
blood but like there's that one shot
where they cut really wide and it's the
spray out in the field i thought that
was really striking or you know when
they when he does the thing with the
snake
uh you know you see it through the back
of the the camouflage so like there are
clever ways of not quite showing you or
not showing you in certain moments that
again just speak to a certain level of
like
sophistication i feel like in the
direction i feel like you know you can
approach something like this with a
certain amount of uh gusto and a certain
amount of
sort of abandon but also i think you
know like clever uses of restraint or
clever kind of turns of the screw
on a certain detail or whatever can just
make all the difference and so yeah this
is one of those movies that that
manages to kind of transcend what it is
by just doing what it's trying to do
really well and with a ton of
consideration and with the right amount
of compassion and again like it's a
really great movie at showcasing
perspectives just as much as it is at
building up horror and putting you like
right into the adrenaline rush of these
you know crazy ass fight sequences and
yeah like
the way she ultimately takes the
predator down i was like you know what
in this heightened little world i do
believe this i do believe that after all
she's learned and with that edge of
figuring out that the helmet is the
crucial bit those targeting lasers are
the crucial bit if she can co-opt that
and she can trap him and she can you
know use all of her other skills if she
can make herself invisible and i love
that too they faked us out with the mud
she takes the um
orange tutsia i think they call it you
know the flower that makes your blood
all cold and of course i mean that's a
bit of an action-moving moment because
she's not like convulsing but you know
who knows maybe she's been micro dosing
very often up until that point to build
up a tolerance um but yeah like you know
she steps aside as the guy who walks up
to the really horrible nasty trapper guy
and uh and yeah it's like she uses her
original plan she lures him out with the
bait and then she uses the gun the gun
finally works and i love that too like
the guns
rarely amount to much they do a couple
times but you can't like that one guy
with the ricochet like killing himself
basically um and then you know not
obviously uh taking the shot at the back
of the predator's head but like yeah the
way they earn her taking him down at the
end at least to me felt very well
assembled and very well acted and very
well conceived from a story standpoint
because yeah you are watching two
budding hunters learn and one is
obviously at an advantage and knows a
lot more and is you know the odds are
stacked
in one side's favor at the beginning
obviously but the way they went about
you know making
that story uh you know come together and
making her you know sort of this
triumphant figure by the end i i really
enjoyed it and i felt like it was very
much earned and i liked the way that
they took
a few different kinds of movie here you
know you have your predator movie your
action horror monster movie but you also
have
you know like i said i think early on in
the reaction like when you dip out of
that and you just go back to life in the
camp for a little while or life is there
on this hunt you really get pulled into
that stuff too and the movie cares just
as much about that stuff and knows how
to make that stuff just as engaging from
a character level but also as engaging
from just an action from an intensity
level that yeah like all the pieces are
interesting and all the pieces are just
the right amount nothing really outstays
its welcome nothing feels too brief to
me like this was a slam dunk like like
this is all that it needed to be and and
all the right kinds of more as far as
i'm concerned so i had a blast with this
if you couldn't tell leave me your
thoughts i would love to hear what you
guys thought of this i hope you guys
enjoyed watching along with me and uh
yeah we will catch you
for more uh movie reactions going
forward this is a lot of fun and uh yeah
sound off in the comments like and
subscribe and all that good stuff and
i'll catch you on the next one much love
and as always cheers